[Música]
llegó la hora de la información
económica en france 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero luís
méndez luis bienvenida iniciamos
hablando de la guerra en ucrania y una
nueva ronda de sanciones que alista la
unión europea para presionar a rusia que
se retire del territorio ucraniano algo
que hasta el momento no ha logrado y
sería la sexta ronda de sanciones de
acuerdo con lo manifestado por el jefe
de la política exterior de la unión
europea josep por el que además agregó
que éstas estarían apuntando
particularmente a las importaciones de
petróleo ruso escuchemos que mayo
habrá más bancos rusos que saldrán del
sistema swift y el sector energético
estamos trabajando para preparar
propuestas que permitan limitar las
importaciones energéticas de rusia
especialmente en lo que se refiere al
petróleo ayer en una reunión de
ministros de energía del bloque de los
27 se dio el respaldo de alemania para
un embargo a las importaciones de gas y
petróleo procedentes de rusia pero se
han encontrado con la oposición de
hungría y eslovaquia por un lado
recordemos que viktor orbán el primer
ministro húngaro se han mostrado afín
con el gobierno de vladímir putin pero
más allá de eso la nación importa
alrededor de un 85 por ciento del gas y
otro 65% del petróleo que consume
procedente de rusia para eso va que el
caso es más complejo puesto que además
de los altos porcentajes de importación
cuentan con refinerías exclusivas para
el refinamiento del petróleo ruso y
cambiar esta tecnología podría tomar
años louis pero que está haciendo
entonces la unión europea para disminuir
la dependencia del gas y del petróleo
ruso y poder cumplir con estas sanciones
valentina vale decir que están buscando
diversos mecanismos para poder mantener
el suministro de gas y petróleo sin que
ello afecte a la economía de cada uno de
estos países de hecho la agencia
independiente de noticias conoce de
moscú interfax ha señalado que el bloque
buscan nuevos proveedores eeuu se está
convirtiendo en uno de ellos pero
también se han acercado a través de la
cooperación con algunos países africanos
en otras acciones están invirtiendo o
acelerando proyectos energéticos como el
visitado por charles michel el
presidente del consejo europeo en el
norte de grecia y que podría comenzar a
operar a partir del próximo año bueno
cambiamos de tema porque la organización
para la cooperación y el desarrollo
económico ve avances alentadores en la
transparencia fiscal de américa latina y
el caribe así se desprende del informe
de la segunda edición de su informe para
una redundancia transparencia fiscal en
américa latina pero alertó que los
progresos siguen siendo desiguales
con el texto 13 de los 16 países
vinculados a la declaración de punta del
este uruguay entre ellos colombia se
consideran el intercambio de información
como una alta prioridad mientras que
otros tres tienen un nivel moderado en
este particular el texto señala que la
región ha mejorado sus resultados en el
estandarte intercambio de información
previa petición el año anterior al
tiempo que algunos países han
implementado estrategias para aumentar
esta situación por escuchemos que fue lo
que dijo salida maná está secretaria del
foro durante la presentación del informe
así que hay algunos países que están en
muy más avanzado y otros países que
están empezando este esta utilización
bueno en chile el gobierno rebajó la
previsión de crecimiento para el año
2022 recordemos que el anterior gobierno
de sebastián piñera había situado esta
estimación en un 35 por ciento para el
presente año pero el martes el ministro
de hacienda mario marcel que vale decir
fue presidente del banco central de
chile entre diciembre de 2016 y enero de
este año reveló durante la presentación
informes y finanzas públicas ante una
comisión del parlamento que la economía
chilena crecería alrededor de 15 puntos
porcentuales para este año bajo el
argumento que el gobierno anterior
sustento las cifras en números
optimistas pero que la revisión a la
baja es más realista atado al contexto
mundial bueno de chile vamos al otro
lado del globo pasamos a hong kong
porque allí la economía se contrajo
durante el primer trimestre de este año
así se desprende de los otros
anticipados del departamento de censos y
estadísticas del gobierno de la región
administrativa especial de hong kong la
economía de este
espacio se redujo alrededor de un 4%
anual durante el primer trimestre en
comparación con el mismo período del año
2021 con ello pone fin a una racha de
expansión durante los cuatro trimestres
anteriores en medio de una demanda débil
y también tanto interna como externa les
vamos con los indicadores de las horas
por supuesto que en eeuu están a la
expectativa de lo que puede hacer la
reunión de la reserva federal y por ello
los números cerraron con optimismo con
números positivos en los países en
mercados de wall street una situación
que también se había trasladado temprano
a europa donde hubo cierres positivos
durante la presente jornada américa
latina debido al impacto de la inflación
y algunas políticas económicas cerró con
números mixtos a lo largo de la jornada
y cerramos con la cifra el día en este
caso tiene que ver con un dulce que
usted le gusta mucho estamos hablando de
los alfajores y la estimación de ventas
diarias para este 2022 que se sitúa de
acuerdo con la asociación de golosinas
argentinas en 10.5 millones de favores
vendidos diariamente recordemos que
desde el pasado primero de mayo estamos
en las semanas del favor y serían muchos
los que he consumido yo luisa ustedes
muchas gracias por esta información
económica ya lo invitamos a continuar
con nosotros para ir directo a para
conectar con nuestros corresponsales